[Music]
jeremy welcoming
daniel henry hey
[Applause]
so i work at our studio in the the thai
devos team
and uh today i'll be talking about
interactivity and programming
in the thai divorce so
this is about the notion of data masking
in r
which is this idea that you can blend
the data with the workspace
so that you can work with the the
columns in your data frames
as if they were objects in your
workspace
and i think that's a really great and
unique feature of our
that it helps to turn ideas into
software because you're
directly working with your data rather
than worrying about the data structure
that it is in on the other hand
it does make some things more difficult
and in particular it makes it more
difficult to reuse code to
write functions about around data
masking functions
so we have made progress in the tooling
to solve that issue and and also in the
teaching in our approach to teaching it
so if you have learned a little bit
about ideaval before
we'll see some new concepts here the
concept that you have learned before are
still
relevant we still use the bank bank
operator all the time when we
create our tools but this should be
considered
lower level tools and now we are going
to see higher level approach
right so i would like to talk a little
bit about the the history
of data masking in r so
in 1998 the blue book was published that
defined
the s language which is the ancestor of
r
and a lot of the things that we still
use were in that book
and one of the first manifestation of
data masking
was in the attach function which allows
you to
take a data set and attach it to the
search path
the same way that you do with the
package so that's a little bit different
from data masking but it's still the
idea that
the data frame is the is the important
scope and that
if you are working interactively with r
you want to
uh to be able to work with the data
directly
so attach is not the recommended way of
working with
uh with data for now
but a few years later
the white book was published and it was
about all of the statistical modeling
functions that we still using are now
so the like the lm function and the way
that that works
is that they took a data frame and a
formula
and in the formula you have data masking
you can you can refer to your
to your columns directly and then
r was being developed in the 90s
and peter dargaard who is a member of
harcourt
published the frame tools package which
was really fundational for rm for the
tie divorce and for
4d player and so as you can see you
had the subset frame function the select
frame function and modify frame
and the these are um
so these are the the same kind of
function that we have in the player like
filter select
and mutate and you could use data
masking to filter rows
you could select columns and modify
columns inside the data frame
and that was the first operation of
selections
which is a little bit different from
data masking
so in particular you can use the column
operator to select
a range of variables that are contiguous
in your in your data frame
and other features that make it really
easy to to select columns
so these were integrated in r subset and
select were merged into one single
function
modify became transform
and then there were relatively few
developments
on data masking in base r uh
we had the risk function was included
and
the within function a few years later
but by and large
most of the developments happen in
package space so in 2006
the data table package was released for
the first time
and um what one of the things that it
did besides performance is that it
allows you to use data masking
in i to subset rows and you could use
data masking j but also selections
to select columns then 2014
the player was released so very similar
to the
to the ideas that were in the frame
tools package
but with the objective to really push
data masking in a much more
comprehensive
api so
what was the reason that uh development
of the
data masking slowed down in base r i
think we can find the answer in the
the documentation topics for subset and
transform
and if you read those you will see this
warning
that they are really convenience
functions intended for use interactively
that the non-standard evaluation can
have an unanticipated consequences
so i think what they mean by that is
that
it's about the the ambiguity between
data variables so variables that are in
your data frame
and any environment variables those that
are in your workspace that you have
assigned with the arrow operator
and this ambiguity causes two different
problems that are distinct but related
first you can get unexpected masking
from data variables
and secondly um data variables cannot
get
through function arguments and that
makes it difficult to create functions
around
data masking functions and so we are
going to see
solutions that we offer in the tie
device to solve these issues
so first about unexpected masking that's
about the problem
so let's say that you have created an
object
n in your workspace it contains a number
and you have a data frame with an x
column
and you want to modify it create a new
column that divides
the column x by the number uh inside of
n
and the problem is that the data frame
is really a moving part
and if you are using the same code with
different data frames maybe they don't
contain the same
the same columns and if you uh
if you get a data frame that has a
column n
then uh and the column has precedence
over the object
in the workspace the column masks the
objects in the workspace and you get
the wrong result
so that's not that's not a big problem
if you are working interactively through
your script
doing an analysis because you know what
kind of objects you have in the
workspace
you know the columns that are in your
data frames
but if you are writing production code
that can be an issue
because your your same code will be
used across many different data frames
from different users
so the solution here is to be explicit
when you are
writing projection code and to do that
you use the data
pronoun or the dot inf pronoun and these
pronouns are
available in all of the data masking
functions in in
the thai device and so here we are
again modifying the data frame but this
time we are dividing dot data dollar
x by dot in dollar n
and now we have we are completely
explicit about where the data comes from
and we have resolved the ambiguity
so the second problem that data
variables cannot get through
function arguments that makes it
difficult to create functions around
tide diverse pipelines so let's say that
we have
this mean by function where we have some
data
and we group by one variable and we
summarize
by taking the the average of another
variable
and so we take one data frame and two
variables that we
passed to group by and summarize and we
get
and so if we call this mean by function
with data variables like species
we get this error that column by is
unknown
so what happens here is that inside the
function we are referring to the
dysfunction argument which is an
environment variable
by and when you call the function you
are supplying a data variable species
and that that's how r gets confused and
it
doesn't know what you really meant
so the solution is to is to tunnel
the data variable through the
environment variable and
to tunnel a data variable you use this
new operator
uh correctly which was added in rlang
last year and that that allows
the the color of your function to use a
data variable
and it will get forwarded through the
environment variable and evaluated in
the data frame as it should
so one other issue that you might have
is that we have hardcoded the result
name here
we have given it the name of avg for
average
but maybe you want to have something
that
that changes with the input so
a very new feature in our link that i
just got here
last week that you can now use glue
strings on the
left hand side of the wall race operator
so the syntax is a little bit different
from the group package because you
have to use double curly and that allows
you to tunnel
a data variable through the uh inside
the string and then
you get you get a more relevant
result name in the resulting data frame
one issue with tunneling is that it
causes data masking to propagate
so now your function is also a data
masking function because
you know you can supply data data
variables in it
and that means that the users of your
function
will have to know about that they will
have to know about the ambiguity
if they are writing production code they
will have
to know about the curriculum operator if
they want to write
a function around your your function
and so one question is could we
could we make is there a way to easily
create functions
but without the data masking propagation
so if we go back to the dot data pronoun
that we have subsetted with the dollar
operator with
constant column names species and
simple.width
and let's say that now you want to
subset column names which are in
variables then you use the
double bracket operator as you would in
normal r code
and now that means that you that we are
using
environment variable that contains the
the column names
and so you build your function around
that you take your data frame
you take the two variables and now you
have
a completely normal function that takes
column names as strings
and you don't have any data masking
anymore which can be
which can be better when you are working
in an organization and working with
co-workers which maybe don't know about
data masking that i diverse or all that
and in this case if you want to
customize the
result name you use again the glue
string but this time with the
normal single curly
operator
so that's how you deal with these two
programs you if you have
uh unexpected masking and you're worried
about that use the dot data and dot inf
pronoun to the
disambiguate and if you want to create
functions
and deal with the problem of taking
arguments which might contain data
variables you tunnel them
with the double curly operator or you
subset the data with
the double bracket if you want to take
column names that's during this instance
so what about selections as we have seen
selections are a bit different they are
kind of a separate sub language
especially in the the thai device
functions and the reason for that is
that
data variable in selection so for
example if you use the select function
in the player but also
pivot wider pivot longer and tidier use
selections
and in this selection data variables
represent the locations
inside the data frame and that's
actually the reason why that you can use
the
the colon operator because if you say
colon name colon math
that's really the same as writing one
column three and you create this
sequence
of locations from which we know where to
get the variables from
but that means that ambiguity is much
less an issue when you
are working with selections so let's say
that you have
a character vector of column names
which is assigned in the name
environment variable
and the star wars data frame also
contains a data
a column that that's called name but if
you write select
name that's that's a data variable so it
will be
you will be selecting uh the column name
and if you want to disambiguate and use
the character vector that you have saved
in your object in your workspace
you use olaf so if you've
if you're familiar with onef uh all off
is a new function that's a little bit
stricter
and that has better properties um it
like if you when you use all of
uh it means that you want you are
expecting all the columns in
uh in the character vector to be in the
data frame and if they are not there you
will get
an error whereas one off was throwing a
warning instead
so we you have a little bit uh more
strict here
right so if you have if you want to
create a function around the selection
function you
just take the data frame and then the
variable
a variable containing the the column
names
and you just use select all of and this
the function arguments
and then you have a normal function and
your user can call them with
uh with character vectors but you can
also
use the double quality operator and in
this case it means that you are
tunneling the selection
uh from across the function
and in this case uh in the same way that
if you use the the
curly curly uh with a data masking verb
and you create a data masking function
then your function becomes a selection
function
and that means that your user can call
can use the selection helpers like start
with
so that's it that's uh those are the new
features
and the the tweet like uh
like i'm sorry
what sorry i'm crushing them
yeah so if you want to disambiguate
the uh the data variables from the
environment variables you use the data
you use the data pronoun and the dot and
if you have data masking
if you are using a selection function
use olaf
and in case you want to tunnel data
variables and selections you use the
query color operator thanks
thank you danielle we do have some
questions here yep um the first one says
are these new features to replace
or be alternatives to cool and bang bang
no like like these are higher level
features
that are meant to be easier to use for
for people that don't don't want to get
into meta programming and learning
these hard skills but all the lower
level programming tools are here to stay
and we
we use them to to build these tools
ourselves great
um also uh can you clarify the
difference between all off
and everything with select i'm sorry
the difference between the all off that
you just showed and
everything yeah so everything means that
you want to select everything
and olaf means that you are only
selecting the the columns that are
inside
the character vector that you supply
thank you um the last one i have here
is there a timetable for implementing um
curly curly curly or super stash
uh no no that's not that's not plant not
plant
okay uh one more it says it's all
elements of the syntax supported by db
player and sparkly r
sorry can you repeat this um are these
uh uh supported by dd player and sparkly
r
yeah uh deployer for sure sparkly i
don't know
about that but i would guess so because
they are probably using play diva
i agree yeah and last one does
curly curly work with multiple variables
no only only one function argument so
you're really
it's really meant to use with function
arguments inside functions
only thanks so much appreciate it